A GREAT WEEKEND.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH, BRIAN.
>> Brian: WE FORGE AHEAD.
AFTER TUESDAY'S MIDTERMS
TUCKER SAT DOWN WITH FORMER
SENATOR, ONE OF THE GREAT
GUYS IN WASHINGTON JOE
LIEBERMAN.
HERE IS HIS CONVERSATION
WITH INDEPENDENT JOE.
>> Tucker: SENATOR, THANKS A
LOT FOR JOINING US TONIGHT.
>> I'M DELIGHTED, TUCKER.
>> GOOD TO BE BACK WITH YOU.
>> Tucker: THANK YOU.
SO, AS THE RESULTS ARE
COMING IN LAST NIGHT, AND IT
WAS CLEAR THAT THE DEMOCRATS
WERE GOING TO RETAKE THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES AS
PREDICTED, MSNBC ANNOUNCED
THAT ONE THE TOP PRIORITIES
OF THE INCOMING CONTROLLING
PARTY WOULD BE TO OBTAIN
DONALD TRUMP'S TAX RETURNS.
DO YOU THINK THAT THE
MANDATE OF THIS ELECTION?
>> I DON'T.
WHETHER THEY GO FOR THE
PRESIDENT'S TAX RETURNS OR
NOT IS UP TO THEM.
BUT THAT CERTAINLY SHOULDN'T
BE THEIR PRIORITY.
I WANT TO GIVE YOU MY
PERSONAL PERSPECTIVE.
I'M THE CHAIRMAN OF A GROUP
CALLED NO LABELS.
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING TO
ENCOURAGE BIPARTISAN IN
CONGRESS.
AND THIS YEAR FOR THE FIRST
TIME WE ACTUALLY GOT INTO
CAMPAIGNS OF PEOPLE WHO WERE
PART OF WHAT WE CALL THE
PROBLEM SOLVERS CALCULATION.
WE RAISED OVER $50 MILLION.
WE SUPPORTED 28 CANDIDATES.
14 REPUBLICANS, 14
DEMOCRATS.
MEMBERS OF THE PROBLEMS
SOLVER CAUCUS.
23 WON.
THE DEMOCRATS WHO WON WHICH
I THINK IS WHY THE DEMOCRATS
NOW CONTROL THE HOUSE WERE
ACTUALLY MORE MODERATE,
INDEPENDENT-MINDED PROBLEM
SOLVERS.
SO I DON'T THINK THEY'RE
GOING TO GO TO CONGRESS TO
GET PRESIDENT TRUMP'S TAX
RETURNS.
I THINK THEY ARE GOING TO GO
TO TRY TO GET SOMETHING DONE
FOR THEIR CONSTITUENTS AND
THEIR COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: SO, AND I THINK
ALL OF US HOPE THAT THAT
HAPPENS.
>> YES.
>> Tucker: BUT, IT DOES
RAISE THE QUESTION WHO IS IN
CHARGE OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY?
SO IS THAT CAUCUS BIGGER
THAN THE ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ CAUCUS WHICH
IS SUBSTANTIAL?
>> I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY --
I DON'T THINK THERE ARE MANY
PEOPLE WHO ARE EXACTLY WHERE
CONGRESSWOMAN ELECT
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ IS.
A SELF-PROCLAIMED SOCIALIST.
I THINK WEAK ON FOREIGN
POLICY AND DEFENSE POLICY.
BASICALLY WANTS THE
GOVERNMENT TO TAKE OVER A
LOT OF THE ECONOMY.
BUT, WHAT WORRIED ME WHEN
SHE WAS ELECTED, TUCKER, WAS
THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE,
INCLUDING SOME POTENTIAL
DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATES BEGAN TO RUN
AFTER SOME OF THE POSITIONS
SHE WAS TAKING, INCLUDING
CALLING FOR THE ABOLISH NOW
OF ICE, THE IMMIGRATION AND
CUSTOMS ENFORCEMENT AGENCY.
YOU MAY DISAGREE WITH THEIR
POLICIES.
BUT HOW SCREW A COUNTRY
WHERE THERE IS NO GROUP
ENFORCING IMMIGRATION AND
CUSTOMS LAWS.
SO I THINK THIS IS -- WHAT
HAPPENED YESTERDAY WAS GOOD
FOR DEMOCRATS IN THE HOUSE.
BUT IT'S ALSO A WARNING.
I THINK THEY REGAINED THE
MAJORITY BY RUNNING MORE
MODERATE CANDIDATES IN
SUBURBS.
AND MODERATE DEMOCRATS,
ACTUALLY, LOST IN THE SENATE
AND THAT SHOWED, I THINK,
SOME STRENGTH IN PRESIDENT
TRUMP WHO WORKED HARD TO
DEFEAT A LOT OF THOSE
MODERATE DEMOCRATS.
SO THERE IS GOOD NEWS AND
BAD NEWS AND WARNINGS FOR
BOTH PARTIES HERE.
AND THE LAST THING THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY SHOULD DO,
IF IT WANTS TO HAVE A CHANCE
TO WIN THE PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION IN 2020 IS TO
FOLLOW AFTER CONGRESSWOMAN
ELECT OCASIO-CORTEZ.
THERE IS JUST NOT MANY
PEOPLE WHO BELIEVE THAT IN
AMERICA, THANK GODS.
>> Tucker: I DON'T KNOW HOW
MANY DEMOCRATIC STRATEGIST
WATCH THIS SHOW.
I HOPE ALL OF THEM AND I